Korske uvičke primude,
da imamo pravna pravila,
koji imaju poljeđenosti
u kulturnisani države.
Pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa kulturnisani države
koja su pozvana čeo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti.
Tu imamo državne grane
na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije imamo isti
stepen vlasti i imamo saradnje.
To je ono što smo u prošlom puno radili
i gdje smo se jedan da zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje. Kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos.
prema državi kao organizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svojstavništvo.
Taj državni aparat čine
samo neki ljudi. Ti
ljudi ti čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim
službenim ulicima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime za račun države.
E sad, tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određenom poslušću.
Dakle,
imate potređeno državno službeno lice,
dakle da rada neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu nadle.
Ja se budim dakle
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim.
Ne da se držim tih definicija iz učbenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da vam objasnim.
Uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom licu
i kažeš evo ti na radi to.
To je tvoja nadležnost.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti.
U principu je ova treća nekakva
funkcionalna, uopšte nije zakonska
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti.
Prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
hordana, ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno u lice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službeno u lice, da li oni radi isti.